he transformed all society in a quiet
modest way and i actually met him once
and it's very strange when you meet a
great person that nobody knows about
because they're just like everybody else
except he had a
mild miss western accent my friend
uh philip nazir says that he used to
talk as though he was like donald duck
nauseas is french and so he was saying
quack quack quack he wasn't like that at
all
well i'm trying to draw the symbol for
the transistor which has a circular
element
and then there is
a base
and then the wires coming in
and going out so there might be currents
coming in there well you take a slab of
material using a semiconductor like
silicon or germanium and you put in
impurities in it dot it in there so that
if these impurities give out electrons
you're going to have an excess of
electrons in this
bit and you have another one over here
with an excess of these particles and
lots of electrons and then inside you
put
another material where there are
positive charges in here so these are
meant to be electrons and these are
meant to be positive charges and you
make a sandwich so this would be
negative
positive
negative
and you
cram them together and make them all
join together so that the electrical
currents can go through this and then
you put attach electrodes here and
electrodes there and electrodes there
and you have a device where you can
change the properties in here by
shifting what's called the chemical
potential in there and that changes the
electrical properties of the current
flow the flow through here and it's as
though it's a sluice gate and you have a
flow of liquid through here
push the salute down the flow through
there is reduced lift it up and it it
increases and you can do this very
quickly because this is electronic it's
not governed by mechanical effects the
other reason i chose it is the person
who did this was john bardeen
who with brattain and shockley got the
network prize for this but bardeen was
so very
talented that he got the nobel prize
also for discovering the theory of super
conductivity that is uh metals whose
conductivity is zero they
currents can flow without resistance so
there were two things that he did both
of which got the nobel prize
that set him apart
yeah i mean there are some people that
you regard of in the theoretical physics
world as being
unbelievable i mean he transformed all
society in a quiet modest way and i
actually met him once
and it's very strange when you meet a
great person that nobody knows about
because they're just like everybody else
except he had a
mild mis western accent
and we were at a conference in grenoble
in 1978 and my son was a year old and
this great physicist picked my son up
and cuddled him for a while so i've
always had a very soft spot for bardeen
and when it came to do research first i
picked on a topic that john bardeen had
chosen the paper by bardeen bayman pines
and worked on that field for several
years so this is one of my heroes my
friend
uh philip nauzier says that he used to
talk as though he was like donald duck
nauseas is french and so he was saying
quack quack he wasn't like that at all
he was easy to understand but he was
very shy and
self-effacing and yet he's
had more to be proud of than anybody
else i thought originally when you came
to see me that you just wanted
symbols in physics which were going to
be letters greek letters
whatever and that's the things we use
all the time and i suddenly thought well
we could have a whole plethora of
symbols which are used in other ways
such as the transistor and this seems to
me the thing that's changed our lives
more than anything and i could write
down lambda mu and new and all the other
ones and trying to blind you with
science but this is actually what has
transformed people's lives and it's this
symbol that represents to at least to me
the whole concept of taking
different sorts of materials putting
them together making contacts and making
electrical
use of them